[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef who grew
up on the wild side Cassady davines
father was a wildlife biologist and she
spent much of her childhood moving among
the country's national forests that's
where she learned to appreciate nature's
bounty at the peak of freshness her
culinary career also kept her on the
move at worldwide locations of the Four
Seasons Hotel group but then she found
an idyllic place to settle down she is
now executive chef at the barn at
blackberry farm outside Knoxville
Tennessee where the menu includes
produce grown right on the restaurant
grounds and chef Cassidy Dabney is with
us good morning welcome to the dish good
pleasure this looks great what do we
have okay so I always try to get people
to eat beets because people hate beets
with an aged balsamic vinegar and then
we have roasted butternut squash with
hazelnut creme fraiche and dill Brussels
sprouts these take a hot second to prep
with the leaves yeah it's a little bit
of a pain but completely worth it with
some smoked onion jam and chili oil and
then I have rack of lamb because it's
bougie is all hey dinner and then an
apple crisp with a cinnamon and milk tea
and if you're gonna have that you got to
have the red oh yeah here's cheese and
the beets are good this is like a nosh
goes well with about everything or
nothing cheers Cheers
we talked about the way you grew up I
mean you even have like a mushroom
growing kit I understand yeah when I was
10 years old I asked my mom for a
mushroom growing kit because I thought
that would be fun you know when you move
around a ton you don't collect a lot of
things so growing up my toys were
basically food and playing in the
kitchen and getting the antenna on the
TV to get PBS with the tinfoil so that I
could watch great chefs of whatever and
then try to recreate those dishes with
the things that we have in our kitchen
and my parents would bless their hearts
eat these things that were completely
terrible
in retrospect you've made up for it now
I have yeah
go right ahead my dear talk about I mean
the influence of your dad a little bit
more brothers a wildlife biologist so
I'm so intrigued by but what he did for
you and what are you passed on well
there was definitely this instilling in
me and my sister of the importance of
food we he was an avid hunter we grew a
lot of our own food so when you have
that relationship with your food that
you've you've seen it from start to
finish you respect it a little bit more
and you you treat it in a different way
I think now when you think about where
you work now nature is all around you
how does it inspire you to create oh
it's kind of like cheating you just go
to the garden and I'll just be hanging
out in the garden and I look down and
there'll be butternut cuz we were
covered up and butter not this year like
everywhere was better not and then you
look over and then there's dill just
grow eat a couple feet away and you're
like okay I'll put butternut and dill
together and then you look to your other
side and there's a hazelnut orchard so
the dishes kind of write themselves just
based on where everything's growing a
little scavenger yeah also sort of
taking farm-to-table to the next level
yeah yeah yeah and we have a really
great time of foraging on property and
then preserving those things throughout
the year what's the biggest challenge
then yeah it feels like you have
everything at your fingertips but what
is the biggest I think the biggest
challenge for me is or average guest
stays days so you have to have a
different menu every night of their stay
right so there's three separate menus
and then just finding the inspiration to
do 48 dishes every season yeah oh I know
you keep a notebook for spring in
particular what about the rest of the
season you have to keep a notebook for
all of the seasons like I'm already
working on winter right now and hoping
that I can wrap that up before winter
actually hits so I have some just sign
our dish please you don't have to think
about your menu right in this moment and
ask you if you could have this meal with
anyone pastor present who would it be oh
that's easy
without lis pardon lady that wrench
Joleen and what's that other song in the
same night the
from ask you to sing but thank no more
on chef Dabney on the dish you can head
to our website at
cBS This Morning Calm